welcome to this video coverage for it is
around nine right yes round nine of the
joshimath memorial also it's the
penultimate round so the all-important
mount that sets the the picture for the
for the final games tomorrow so what I'm
going to look at is the game kawana with
white against mamedyarov the two other
games were a job of cards and kayaking
Nakamura both of those games ended in
draws um raja baath carson was a very
very long game more than 100 moves and
yeah most of these moves starting from
let's say about new 40 were in a very
very close position where cards was
trying to to do something he had a very
very little symbolic advantage but never
really yeah no real winning chances
whatsoever so it ended in a draw
kayaking Nakamura was some somewhat to
my surprise the Kings Indian kayaking
went for a closed opening with I think
he's played deform I wasn't Knight f3
not sure but we had a king's indian most
of the game i like 'no cameras
positioned a bit better but at the end
it was still a draw with the precise
play by both sides so the game that i
will look in at in more depth here in
the game of the day is kiwana
Mammadyarov let's see what happens and
we got Slav defense again really some
yeah in a way together with the green
for the most popular opening nowadays I
think it's a bit of a shame that in this
tournament which is in memory of
Fukushima off that absolutely no one has
played the modern benoni up to Nami
because this is really
bin gaseum of trademark opening and no
one went for that well okay there is a
final round and maybe someones got the
the heart to to play that would be very
nice okay so a Slav here with 43 the
slow Slav as it is very often called
yeah very much due to the fact that
white has problems getting something
here and yeah here this is very solid
the following lines and even there's
also a six we're also wide is struggling
to do something with e3 wide is avoiding
both of these lines okay you can you can
state that why not e 6 after e3 of
course that's a play will move but it's
probably a little bit imprecisely and as
white it's not for us to go to a semi
Slav he can also play other moves
especially b3 is interesting aiming for
this type of setup we have seen this set
up various sub x various is a bit much I
think two or three times in the
candidates tournament where it was
played by chronic and wondering this
game that Allen there was a game with
Island black also with the setup bishops
on b2 and b3 yet here black has
committed to c6 already so e6 while
being playable of course it's not
considered to be a yeah a completely
reliable line compared to others so
Mammadyarov is going for Bishop g4 here
earlier in the tournament we had seen
Bishop f5 here or a 693 Bishop f5 these
are the the main lines nowadays Bishop
g4 is also here played today is also a
1-1 Maine moose
of course it's um the typical idea that
black wants to develop is Bishop outside
of the pawn chain so it does not have
any problems with it on c8 however the
drawback to that is well if you send
your Bishop to an adventure it might get
too lost or court and quite often you
must give up the bishop giving white the
bishop pal we see that Normandy are
affirmed follows an interesting idea
after this into queen bee three he went
Queen b6 and now car wanna play tonight
h4 this is some an online for a number
of years and here a recent trend is for
black to play the funny foof g5 and get
this is a move that let's say 40 50
years ago probably would have raised
quite a few eyebrows because it was very
uncommon in in in those days to move the
jeep on early and use flank pawns to to
learn to influence the game early but in
fact this g5 move with it makes some
sense it wins the temple on the night
the night must retreat well
theoretically what can play g4 but it's
not really good neither free and now
aged 60 black has gained those moves
there's the possibility sometimes to
fianchetto and you have gained some
space while securing your bishop yeah
like is not giving up the bishop purely
so this might look a bit unconventional
but it seems to be a good term a good
way to play 95 this is interesting of
course why this intending to maybe take
here on g6 we've seen something like
that earlier in the tournament I think
it was that come we are playing black
rides who got this position with app
takes g6 not one hundred percent sure I
would need to look it up but okay
Mammadyarov wants to avoid that all
together quickly exchanging the
well let's say inviting in exchange and
corona refused that he just retreated
the night to d3 this is a very important
move it's pretty obvious to a strong
player but it is very common for for
Lexus for less experienced players to
very often exchanged far too much if
they see in exchange they often go for
it thinking that ok I exchanged
something it probably will make my life
easier and less complicated means less
chances to to make a mistake but that's
really a wrong approach very often it is
better to not trade pieces especially if
you consider this type of position why
does enjoying a space advantage you with
the central pawns and it would only help
like if white would take you have
exchanged the strong night on e5 against
the night on be a tennis in essence so
it's not a good idea to do that just
retreating keep the tension and asks
back ok where are you going to put your
nights and quite often the sort of
regrouping that the other side must do
with all those pieces crammed under the
space takes so much time it still does
not really matter that white has moved
this pm in this case a third time ok
Bishop g6 age for Rupe g8 yeah of course
like it didn't intend to Castle short
anyway so rook G aids makes lots of
sense got the straight and Bishop t2 ya
hear momma Dee are affirmed decided to
to clarify the situation in the center
he took on c4 and played Queen a6
getting rid of the Queen's which as
mentioned makes lots of sense black is
slightly cramped he's got those pawns
all relatively far back and why it has
some space advantage so you want to
trade yeah white cannot really avoid the
Queen trait if he moves the Queen away
just oh wait b7 is hanging need to think
about that quickly but there's not be 60
black can just take you and win apiece I
was briefly
irritated by this possibility but there
is Knight b6 covering a 8 and preventing
any checks so after Queen a six white
must allow Queen trade he did sell with
91 traded Knight b6 and night 837 yeah
why does occupying some space in the
center there should be seven and 93 all
this looks very very natural the night
CM are positioned to cover the center
and black it's eager to gain some space
so he's attacking the center directly
with f5 this was not strictly necessary
but i think it's it's a good move its
maybe it's very direct and active so you
need to be very precise after that black
could also easily have been going for
something and less enterprising let's
say castles King b8 just sit and wait
maybe this was was easier to play
however objectively speaking at five is
ok f3 white supports the center and a5
trying to push the a pawn to disturb
white a bit and also this way you make
some use of your look at the moment you
know acknowledging that you're probably
not going to cancel long you use your
rook just from the initial square and
push the flank pawn this can very often
be a useful device if you recognize that
castling is not really helping you much
and you want to do something with your
works then pushing the flank pawns a
porn edge porn can be a good idea at
times especially if you attack something
or you're gaining space to create
weaknesses here you can attack the night
and Dwight feels obliged to prevent that
it plays a form just physically stopping
the advance yeah and now the the next
couple of moves for Momiji are
are really really interesting um here
would have expected to see G for being
played it looked like them yeah the
logical follow-up to me to this f5 idea
like just advancing further trying to
exchange the pawns to get rid of all the
weaknesses I just thought that this
should be a very close to being equal if
we consider not quite sure what white is
doing now maybe long castles King f2 I
don't know probably a king move to
connect rooks and I thought that like
then could simply trade him maybe even
hear a 94 could be a bit tricky but
still or let's say you play this year
even just going for exchanges here in
the center opening up the position also
bid against the king and this is what I
expected he played five however very
ambitious move yeah white took on f5
yeah the next move was really really
astonishing I was completely taken by
surprise to see that muhammad arif now
didn't take on f5 this looks totally
normal just recapturing but it didn't do
that you went to f7 yeah if he would
have taken here I think that blacks
position I'm should be okay I don't
really see anything dramatic happening
it's very important to note that after
90 for attacking the a5 pond um black
does not really need to fear this you
can just play 95 and operate with this
idea not be for threatening 92 and this
seems to guarantee black about equal
play for example if white grab cm you
can just continue in active fashion with
G for exchanging here a weakness and
keeping this idea in reserve
why does not really have anything great
if he secures this bishop again Michael
probably take and play night before yeah
and the threat is some really
substantial why probably needs to do
something like that to cover situ and
after capturing and getting the pawn
back it's very much clear that black
shouldn't have any serious problems
there are only three points left and
there's no one nothing concrete going on
especially considering the bishop had
the bishops don't do much him simply too
much traded yeah however he didn't take
on f5 he went to f7 which is really
strange I mean yeah I'm here koala hat I
think a good chance to establish a quiet
tangible advantage here d 5 was possible
but he didn't do that of course white
needs to do something about the night
what he did is he played Bishop d1 to
cover it just to show what happened
instead d5 was quite good the idea is
then after this for example why takes on
a five yet now we we are in a situation
where white is a porn up and where is
the compensation why does also
threatening just to play G for keeping
the f porn and making a protected passer
out of it and our black black simply has
no compensation whatsoever and this also
applies to other responses so if white
if black m takes with the pawn for
example there is not be 5 a-5 Hanks this
is threatened and also there's the
position of threat of G for keeping the
f5 pawn as a protected passer it's just
very good for right not quite sure where
Cara wanna rejected d5 after Bishop d1
what he played mama geographer was able
to play Knight see form and this is so
in fact probably if at all only very
slightly better for white store Black is
just active and has chances to regain
the pawn 94 was played and now you went
for G for a very active move um not the
only one instead of g4 there were other
possibilities he also could have taken
here which is not a bad idea getting the
bishops and after that only taking on
default or let's say King takes you can
also casts a long I think this should be
quite okay for black however what he did
is also not bad G for getting rid of
this weakness also makes lots of sense
white played Bishop d3 note that the
capture is answered by this move and now
it gets a bit tricky for white there is
this threat 91 but should be three and
if the bishop moves that's probably
necessary Bishop see to then black can
take on g4 and thus activity is that's
very nice for black should be at least
equal so um this is what corona plate
after that we got the straight and long
castles yeah how to assess the position
yeah white white enjoys an extra pawn
the blacks position is not bad ready
he's got active pieces yeah and a pretty
healthy structures though this pawns are
not not weak this will probably trade
and the f pawns well they they need some
protection from white so I think black
should be quite okay here we also see
that in the following moves after King
f2 trades and 95 that black really has
got active play in the center
it should be too yeah and here in this
position black also could have kept the
tension here with move like let's say
Luke GA but I decided to do something
something directly something tactical in
a way he captured on it all and went
from 92 and it seems that this is this
is probably playable um instead there
also was the idea to play Bishop c5 here
going for for a pin and after let's say
rookie one black and try to to get the a
pawn in black has some activity here
that's that's it was a playable option
the problem here is always that these
pawns are dangerous the game
continuation 92 i think was was a bit
better yeah kawana captured this he also
could have played Bishop f3 maybe this
was the better move it's a it's tough to
analyze very a very complicated um black
after that can try something like that
taking and then c5 and rook d3 with some
activity that's really very tough to
calculate black has quite some counter
chances with the two bishops but it's
probably better for why this this line
this is what kawana plate and after
rookie for King III Bishop c5 it looks
really a bit scary but that it still
seems to be okay for white Bishop c3 was
played check and now group g3 check yeah
he also could have taken on it well this
looks like a very young um yeah very
tempting move but after King f4 in fact
it turns out to be not so great here
blacks active rook will be exchanged and
those pawns supported by the king will
decide the game provide so not a really
good option what he played was perfectly
okay gave the check here can you have to
and now the exchange sacrifice on c3
this bishop was just too strong it is a
perfectly playable though why it takes
chat and rookie for with the check yeah
and now we've got we've got equal
material in pawn pawns there are three
points each but black is an exchange
down but has very good chance is to
catch at least one of one of the loose
pawns we see that after King e1 yeah not
ideal but there wasn't really a good
alternative you go here you run right
into this idea yeah so you went back
Bishop here and rook h2 and here exactly
here it's probably the the decisive
moment of this game after Luke h2
Mammadyarov now went for rookie 5 and it
seems that this is simply not sufficient
to to to get a draw here which
blacksville probably can do with bishop
d6 in fact it was possible to to get a
position where maybe it is enough for an
exchange rook g2 for example need to
cover here of course and then Bishop b5
yeah this is just very active those
those pieces and yeah what is why it's
supposed to do now guys got this the
spawning and yeah we can try some moves
King bee to for example okay check and
this is certainly not too great for
white you can try to cover like that but
after move like group III this idea is
renewed and yeah what does not really
have anything great available here
King be too that's Bishop f4 yeah very
tricky position right can try to to to
push the pawn yeah trying something like
that now you cannot go here as this
square simply protected by the rook so
after f6 black should probably take here
and after check check after this we come
to a to a draw an endgame and I think
this was probably the crucial moment but
should be 6am with the idea to get the
bishop to to e5 probably would have
drawn the game after rookie 5 however
there was f6 and now this is very
dangerous spawn black really has no
choice he must get the pawn and this is
only possible with this exact sequence
of moves check and now white rates the a
porn for the f1 that's unavoidable
really if black wants to capture wants
to keep this here let's say it plays be
six then white has just check and place
f7 intending route d1
check yeah this was played and now
Bishop edge fry we see that now we get
exactly the described trade yet here the
problem is that white will relatively
quickly get his looks coordinated and
detect the the black pawns this is
probably a position that you cannot hold
can we see that kawana manages to to
activate his rooks and now he
coordinates both rooks to attack the
weak spot in blacks camp the b7 porn
yeah it only continued for a couple of
moves from here King b8 look at seven
bishops e7 rock before and check here
mummy geographer resigned he cannot
prevent b7 from being from being
captured and there is some yeah no
resistance anymore um so caruana won
this game very tough battle mostly
fought with concrete calculation where
somehow Mammadyarov didn't find the most
precise continuations around here
suddenly also influenced by my time
travel some things are still quite quite
remarkable moves like bishop f7 here one
when just Bishop f5 looks totally normal
quite quite interesting to see this
Bishop f7 idea okay so let's just
quickly assess this in terms of the
overall tournament situation with this
win koala is on plus 2 and has joined
Carlton in in delete cards and of course
also on plus 2 and the good thing is
they play against each other in the
final round Carlton now having the white
pieces after he had lost with black in
the first turn certainly very eager to
win this game with wine I'm pretty sure
he wants to
this event outright and also he wants
her to to even the score with kawana who
had ended card since a very long streak
of of of the unbeaten games yeah I hope
you enjoyed the courage here for the
ninth round I'll be back tomorrow of
course probably with the game cars in
Kara wanna it was very would be very
disappointing if we wouldn't get a great
fight tomorrow okay thanks for watching
I'll be back tomorrow